- Hire somebody.
You're welcome.
(laughing)
That is the fundamental
answer to everything
you're not good at.
Hire somebody that is good at it.
Know it well enough to know
if they're doing it well.
This portion is like, with me,
so I think this is when
you need to get selfish.
Like need to ask your question.
(upbeat music)
Hiring is guessing, firing is knowing.
Like you gotta go fast.
That's how you get shit down,
that's how you figure stuff out.
This is the television
and television is the radio.
So Four Ds motherfuckers.
- With the three studios,
I can't be everywhere
all at once,
- That's right.
- And it's really easy for me
to get the wind taken out of my sails.
- When one of the
locations isn't delivering
on your standard?
- It's the individual people themselves.
- Right.
- So I am like crazy about this,
I'm super, super driven.
I know everybody can be
amazing and successful,
and they just want to pay their bills.
So I'm dealing with apathy.
- Your employees?
- Yeah.
- Okay, so a couple things.
This is really funny 'cause
this is probably the first thing
I ever started really talking
to my dad about as a kid,
as somebody who had like gifted wisdom.
What keeps me super mellow is like
my thought process and
the things I do well
are gifted DNA and circumstances.
So I never get high on my own supply.
It's just so weird that this
is probably the first thing
I started talking to my dad
about when I was 15 years old.
I looked at my dad one
time when we were driving
and I said, Dad if they were you,
they wouldn't work for you.
This is something we talk
about 28 years later.
My dad brings up that statement.
He's like, you were a kid.
Your ideology for what
everybody should be doing
is the quickest way for you to struggle.
There's a very big,
like I have enormous
energy on impacting people
in a good way whether
it's directly attributed
to the people that work
with me or the masses.
Whether that's through heart or hustle,
whatever it may be.
But you have to become deeply aware that
there's only so many
things you can handle.
The other thing that it really leads to is
it leads into you trying to
control something you can't.
This compounds.
And takes over.
- Yeah, for 10 years.
- It's a losing proposition.
First of all, there's a lot of bad in it.
There's a lot of ego and
a lot of your own shit
that you need to really
understand that truth.
It's the same bad that I have.
I create entitlement because I try to
take on too much on myself.
So you gotta be careful with this one.
Here's what I would say.
Your job as somebody that
sits at the top of something
is to put players in the
best position to succeed.
Once you've done that,
you've gotta allow them
to do their thing.
You're a capitalist trying to deploy
almost socialist, communist ideology.
You can't control everything.
Like, there's nothing
wrong with paying your,
what's wrong with paying your bills?
- They're capable of so much more.
- Says who?
You don't know them.
I know Caleb solidly.
I know Nick solidly.
Like, you know don't know.
You're fuckin' spouse and
parents don't know you.
Right?
Let's get to real talk.
There's not a single person on earth
that actually knows you.
Every single person has
certain little subtle things
that they still have not
articulated to the world.
To not one person.
You're being ideological.
To scratch your own itch.
You have to understand that.
I think a bigger thing is
where are you going with that?
I think if you're going
into a place of like,
they could be so much and
we could win together,
which would make sense to me, right?
Let me help you be a better employee,
you'll do better, we'll do better, right?
You're better off firing them.
- I knew you were gonna say that.
I hate firing people.
- Me too!
Me too.
But me hating firing people creates,
what I do with it is I create
entitlement and protect people
at my cost which makes
them think they're better
than they are.
Your not firing people is your imposing
an ideology on them.
You're making it about,
you could be so much,
you're putting it on
them, instead of yourself.
You don't want to fire them
because they're not
capable of over-delivering
or delivering on the
standard of what you need
for your business.
And so they way you're
deploying that resentment
is deploying them to feel bad
that they're not achieving
they're capability predicated on something
that you need them to do in the context
of your four walls.
- So I just need to get
the right people in there.
- I'm at my best when I fire fast,
when I know it's wrong.
And I do that rarely
'cause I don't like it.
But I've gotten better at it.
But you shouldn't create, you know,
resentment comes out
in very different ways.
When I'm resenting something,
I'm razzing people.
Like I'll make jokes.
That's my way of getting it out.
You're not doing any
favors looking somebody
dead in the eye and say
you could be so much more.
It's doing nobody a favor.
It's not doing you a favor,
it's not doing them a favor.
What you need to be thinking about is
first and foremost, the number one thing
you need to be thinking about is
the three managers, or
the one regional manager,
the people that are actually
responsible in the trenches,
that's who needs to be a hundred.
You fix that, you fix everything.
Don't focus on the
sink, focus on the well.
Everything I'm worried about
in the thousand employees here
is predicated on my 11 direct reports
that run those departments.
Got it?
- It's on the managers.
- The managers.
If the three managers are perfect,
then you'll be set.
- And they're not.
- No shit.
(laughing)
I know.
I know, that's how it works.
That's how businesses work.
You've only got two variables
that you're talking about.
This is why it's easy
for me to understand.
I know that they're not right.
And then underneath that,
the employees you have
either they're under performing
'cause the manger blows
and you know it.
Or they've just been around for a while
and you have actual human emotion to them.
And those are both valid.
But the quickest thing that
will make you so much happier
is to make sure the three
managers are phenomenal.
You have three, I would
assume, per location?
- They basically deal
with all the happy stuff.
And if anything goes wrong
I'm the one that has to
come in to deal with that.
- You've created that.
Just like I created it here.
You need to un-create that.
And what is fine at a
smaller business level
and why it worked for me at Wine Library,
when it's smaller there's a level of fine,
but if you have ambition
and for it to grow,
you need to get the value out of the way
you're compensating.
You're better off compensating more
and letting people do the
defense and the shit as well.
- Okay.
Got it.
- Got it?
- [Man] Two questions.
The first one, with combat vet being
kind of my main business,
about 45 percent of my business,
but I was not in the military,
I was not in law enforcement,
so it's a target market
that I appreciate very much,
but I'm not really a part of.
- I think that as long
as you're authentic,
you know, there is a small subset.
In any subculture there's
always a part of that group
that will always be like,
well you're not one of us
so you have no permission here.
But if you speak to admiring something,
as long as you're clear cut about that
and not hiding and trying to avoid,
I think,
I think you'd be surprised on how much of
a non-issue that is for the 89 percent.
- Okay 'cause one of my manger--
- 'cause the 11 percent, yeah,
- Was military, retired military,
and they have their stuff made in China.
But they don't tell anybody that.
They're like, oh we're
military owned and operated.
So they get a lot of business.
I feel like they get a lot
of business because of that.
- And the consumer's always right.
Like you can't focus on that.
You get two moves.
You're more than welcome to
make a video and be like,
look, I have deep admiration
for our law enforcement
and our military and here's why.
And I'm extremely proud that
we make our product in America
and we have competitors in the marketplace
who've been in this space,
but they make their product in China.
And you the customer should decide.
- Would you say that even though--
- Yes.
- Even though they claim to make--
- I would, because that's how I roll.
You don't need to.
I'm not a big fan of
dwelling without action.
Either you never dwell about it again,
or you mention it.
But the middle blows.
That's what you're doing.
That's the game.
The reason I don't complain,
the reason I genuinely don't is
I've got a very basic thesis.
Either I do something about it,
or if I've decided I don't
want to do something about it,
which is many things,
I don't do, there's certain
things that cross places
where I'm not comfortable,
and I keep my mouth shut.
'Cause there's too much
energy wasted in dwelling.
You're competitor has you on defense.
I know nothing about my competitors.
- [Man] It's not really relevant.
- The consumer's the
only thing that matters.
I just don't care.
The whole like, you can learn from them.
I'll learn it anyway.
Plus I'm not worried about the past.
This is what's great about
being in the trenches.
Right?
I have come to learn that
growing up in a liquor store
and a baseball card table,
my whole life was I'm behind something,
somebody's coming, I watch what
they do, something happens.
Consumer.
The end.
So yes, I would, because
I would like to create
the conversation of that.
Because I think it's a
competitive advantage.
Especially if they're
not authentic about it
because then you can get,
you know, people are very curious.
You put it out there, people
start digging, they find.
Right?
On a podcast the other day I mentioned
that I was in a Wrestle Mania.
I showed up at this
Wrestle Mania and I said
I was once in another Wrestle Mania.
I got the clip now, somebody found it.
People dig, people dig.
You set it up, let somebody
else make the expose
if you don't want to go all the way there.
Innuendoing is fun.
- [Man] And I can keep putting clips of us
manufacturing the chips
and nobody else can.
- That's what I would do.
I'd put out the clip
and be like here we are!
In Iowa making the chip.
I don't know, where do you make the chips?
- [Man] Bay Area.
- Great, here we are in
Bay Area making the chips.
Be fun to see our competitors show
where they make their chips.
Everybody knows what you're saying.
- [Man] Right, okay.
My other question is
my story's similar to yours.
My first business card was when I was 12.
- Love it.
- [Man] My sister and
I sold baseball cards
and photo buttons.
- Do you know what's happening
with these sports cards?
Dude.
(laughing)
On a very serious,
I cannot believe what's happening.
I'm like freaking out.
It's coming back.
It's about to happen.
Anyway, nonetheless.
- [Man] So my parents
had a trophy business,
still do, 40 years.
- So cool.
- [Man] That's what I grew up in.
- [Man] So when I decided
to go off on my own,
the business I started was
called ABC Gifts and Awards.
- Why, you wanted to be
first in the Yellow Pages?
- [Man] Yes.
- By the way do you guys
know that that's why
so many companies are named ABC?
The Yellow Pages was so, and triple A,
the Yellow Pages were so
important, the Google of their day,
you wanted to be first,
and the way you hacked
it was by being AAA.
- [Man] My parents were
A&B Creative Trophies
because there was American
Trophies in the same town.
So that was, got ahead of them.
- Isn't that funny?
Cool right?
- [Man] So that's what I started with.
- Aah, Liquors!
I used to think that.
I was like, maybe we should
rebrand to Aah Liquors.
Like when I was a kid,
'cause I realized hacks
came naturally.
Nonetheless.
- [Man] So that's where I started off
but very quickly got to the poker chips.
So the business name didn't
have anything to do with poker
and I never changed it.
But over the years I've
acquired many of my competitors.
So now I'm the Bed of Jacks Poker Supply,
I'm Vierra Pro Poker, I'm Palm Gaming.
But they're still all separate.
So I don't know if I should,
being that it's still 55
percent of the business
is poker, would you say
I should combine all
and start maybe ABC Poker?
Or something?
- Why?
That's the most important.
- [Man] Because it's so fragmented.
- For who?
For you on the backend, for the consumer?
- [Man] I think for the consumers.
For us it's not a problem.
- So for the consumers,
what do you think happens?
- [Man] They get confused I believe.
- Why?
- [Man] Because we've
got different products
on different sites.
So we don't have all the same.
- Do they know that
they're even associated?
- [Man] Some people do, some people don't.
- The question is,
- [Man] Does it matter?
- Does it matter?
And then what are you
trying to accomplish?
To me, the reason to
consolidate is you've got
a big commitment to building a brand.
And that when you flip it,
there's gonna be a delta
on the brand value.
So when you sell a business
or when you value a business
there's the EBITDA of
like, here's the profit.
And then there's the thing above it.
Which is what's the brand worth?
The reason to consolidate
is to build a brand.
I would not call it ABC,
I would create a brand.
That would be the biggest
reason to consolidate,
in my opinion, based
on what you're saying.
- [Man] I don't have any
intention of selling.
- Then there's no crazy
reason other than maybe
you just want to manage one site.
Maybe you're curious on
what it's gonna mean.
Maybe there are some curiosities.
But if you think about it,
I assume these are web-based
driven business, right?
- [Man] Yes, all of them.
- You're gonna give up,
- [Man] Right, that's
why I've never done that.
- No shit.
And you're not giving me
a compelling reason to.
If you're gonna give
up all that SEO juice,
all that brand equity,
all the people that, and I'm gonna guess,
80 percent don't give a
fuck or know that you have
seven other sites.
And know you're gonna consolidate them all
and they're gonna type in, Palm whatever
and it redirects to this.
I know what, but then it's
like aah that's not my.
Dude, let me tell you a great
story about Wine Library.
We built a new store on the
same fuckin' plot of land.
And everybody decided
it was a different store
and that we were more expensive
and we dropped prices.
(chuckling)
People don't like change.
The second you redirect,
they're gonna be like,
this is, somebody bigger bought my people,
and now it's more expensive
or not as good, you know?
I just don't see the value
unless you've got a strategy
for it, you know what I mean?
Does it make sense?
- [Man] Yes, it does.
Thank you.
- You're welcome.
- [Woman] So I really
debated asking you a question
about our company as a
whole or versus my role.
Sorry guys, I'm going with my role.
- Yeah really, this is like,
listen, we're here, right?
Let's do it.
- [Woman] So one of the things I mentioned
is trying to change from the traditional
advertising strategy to a
new way of doing business.
- You're trying to change
other people's opinions of it.
- [Woman] Thank you, yes.
- This is a very important starting point.
- [Woman] Absolutely, and
you're absolutely right.
Change their opinions about it.
It's not an easy thing to do
especially in a small market like Alaska.
- And it's not easy anywhere.
Good news, it's not an Alaska thing.
It's a human thing.
Humans are really good at
putting the past on a pedestal.
And demonizing the current.
Very good at it.
- [Woman] We see it.
One of the titles that I would have
at a traditional agency at my current role
would probably be like client relations.
And we've reworded that.
Same kind of position but it's
the director of client experience.
- Fine.
- [Woman] One thing that I'm
finding myself challenged with
is walking that line
between giving too much.
- Of course.
- [Woman] Because I care so
much about my connections
especially in Alaska.
It's a small market.
- Yeah, reputation, small town.
- [Woman] Yeah, so I found
myself giving some clients
which are those smallest
clients the most attention.
I have no idea how to cut that.
I can identify it when it's happening.
I can see it, I can feel it.
- I love it, it's very easy.
I'm gonna give you really good advice.
Disproportionate honey on top of vinegar.
So we've decided that Sally's
Hair Salon has gotta go.
She's grandfathered in at a rate that we
no longer can deal with.
She's disproportionately time consuming
in return for the ROI.
But she's massively lovely.
It's no different than firing somebody.
You know what my advice to
people who struggle with firing?
Give huge severance.
It works.
Let me play it out for you.
We're all playing this same game.
Ready?
You don't like firing somebody?
Give them four months
severance where most people
just fire them and they
have to go on the street.
I promise you, you're
gonna sit on firing them
for more than four months.
Now you're Mother Teresa and
you've solved your problem.
- [Woman] So you pay them to go away.
- A hundred percent!
You're not valuing
the money isn't as valuable as the time.
You being on defense is so expensive!
You telling somebody, look we're going in
a little bit of a different direction,
I'm giving you a six month head start.
I will help you hire a different agency
or hire somebody.
I'll interview them.
It amortizes out.
You feel great about you,
and you solve the problem
in a way that's disproportionate
honey on top of vinegar.
It is good.
(laughing)
It's good because, I'll
tell you why it's good.
Because I'm a successful
businessman who does that.
I understand it.
What's so fun for me
about giving advice is
I only give advice I know.
And I know this move works for
a certain type of individual.
For my dad, it's the stupidest
thing he's ever heard.
Just walks in and goes, you're fired!
We're done with you Sally.
That's how we rolls.
He's cool like that.
And that's amazing.
That's a strength
that I don't have.
I have my disproportionate
honey with vinegar.
Nobody gives fuckin' two months severance
in the tattoo parlor business.
And by the way, sometimes I've given
disproportionate honey with vinegar,
and they're like you're a fuckin' asshole,
even when I've done
things that make no sense.
But not three years later they come back
and they're like, actually in hindsight,
now that I've lived on the other,
grass is greener,
you're actually extremely nice.
Thank you for that.
That's what you need to do with clients.
You need to fire them in a
way that's amazing for them.
Once you recognize it,
you go into how do I solve this issue.
- [Woman] So do you give
them a time period where
okay, we're gonna work on
this because it's a challenge
on my end.
- Yeah, you make them part of the process.
You walk in and say this is not working
for our business anymore.
You tell them the truth.
Like we're evolving, the time allocation,
I only have so many hours in the day
and the business requires this and so,
but I don't want you to
have collateral damage
from this decision in the short term.
So let's put together
a six month strategy.
We're happy to stay on,
I will try just as hard, if not harder.
I tell people what I'm doing.
I tell them.
I tell people what I'm doing sometimes.
Please.
- [Man] Just to piggy back on that too.
You said something when you
said that it's just not,
like we can't afford it anymore
because we scaled a lot faster
than we thought in one year.
So what we're offering a
year ago is totally not--
- Our business has changed.
Our business has changed,
that's not your fault.
We're so grateful that
you signed up with us
a year ago.
Let me help make the next
six month transition awesome
including helping you hire the replacement
or helping you hire someone internal,
sorry.
- No you're good.
- Doing what we do.
It's honest.
- [Woman] It is honest.
- [Man] That's what's
been done to me before
just to throw that out there.
And I ended up in such a better spot.
So on the receiving side of that offer,
it's worked out great.
- Yeah because once you're half pregnant,
back to giving the advice that I gave you.
Like my ego of, I can't fire this kid,
he doesn't have a college degree.
This is now Wine Library talk.
I do it here where kids can get jobs.
We have a great job market right now.
They've worked at Vayner.
Even now, they have Vayner's
fuckin' in their LinkedIn.
They're more than capable.
And I'm still like, uh.
But there it was,
here it's easy.
There it was impossible.
I was building up kids who
had no other leverage in life
besides the fact that they've
been with me for two years
and it wasn't so easy to replicate
because Wine Library was at
the top of a small thing.
So it wasn't like they're gonna
go to another liquor store
and get that much.
But that was my ego talking.
Every kid that I thought
could not survive in the world
without me, went on and got
another job and survived plenty.
And some did better.
Yeah, so I think that's what you gotta do.
- [Woman] Thank you.
- It will work.
- [Man] Yeah so my
question is kind of like
before that piece happens,
before we get the client,
like you said it happens everywhere
when we're talking to
people and we can show them
case studies or we can show them whatever
and maybe we have four
meetings with these people,
potential client or a lead,
and we're showing them all these things.
Is there anything other than case studies
or showing them actual work that you did
- No.
- to shift that thought
and where do you draw
that line of trying to
- Earlier than you have been.
The thing I'm best at is bailing quick.
I don't try to sell unsellable people.
- [Man] To that topic, you sell them,
you get them on.
Now they're on with you.
You've had the whole
thing and it was great.
We have a client like
this and they're one of
our largest ones.
Now we're in the dirt.
Kind of like okay, here's the game plan,
here's how we move.
And now they're pulling
back and not allowing us
- Yep, happens all the time to us too.
- [Man] To manage that.
Now it's like on what they want.
- I call them, as the
CEO, sometimes and say
look, you hired VaynerMedia and
now you're trying to make us
act like Ogleby.
I go, you should just hire Ogleby.
And then they have to make a decision.
You have to be willing to walk.
Or do what they say.
- [Man] Yeah, absolutely.
It's something we struggle
with all the time.
- And by the way, we're happy,
like I can't get to
everybody in this company
the size that we're in.
We're doing what they
say in plenty of places.
There's not a single client at VaynerMedia
that does exactly what I want them to do.
Not one.
- [Man] Find a balance.
- Yeah, I'm just not ideological.
I have points of view.
I'm very comfortable articulating them.
But I don't have full say,
they're paying me.
- [Man] Right.
- I'm in the client service business.
- [Woman] So we just have to figure out
- [Man] Where the line is.
- Yeah, I mean, that's right.
I think the one thing that will
make a lot of sense to you,
I'm very comfortable doing what
a client's forcing me to do
since they're paying.
My dad, I'm bringing up
my dad a lot which is fun,
my dad had, there's this
great, great Russian saying
that he would always bring up
because it was his leverage.
But like I heard my uncles say it.
It's a classic Russian saying,
you know like whatever
American sayings we have.
It's whoever pays for the
music gets to pick the song.
And I fuckin' love it.
Like I don't know the American,
you know how that's what's great about
knowing other languages
is there's some great,
like I love, clearly I
love analogies and sayings.
I love that one.
That's how I think about VaynerMedia.
They're paying.
Here's the one thing that
you should do though.
You should die on your own sword.
Meaning, no problem big client.
We're happy to do it.
I just want to remind you
that it is our strategy
to do this.
I do that a lot.
- [Man] That's good to hear too
because we've kind of started doing that.
In the beginning we didn't have an option.
- Yeah that's right,
you're like, yes thank you.
Beggars can't be choosers.
There's a good American one.
(laughing)
- [Man] We talked about that so much.
We've been talking about that so much.
In the beginning I felt like we had to,
we'd come with a
proposal, here's the cost.
They come back say absolutely not,
we're gonna pay this much
and we would just do whatever it cost us
- Of course
- [Man] for that amount.
I think we had a major win recently,
we decided, we gave a cost to a client
and they said we can't afford that.
- And you're like, see ya.
- [Man] But we also knocked
down the amount of work
and it went smoothly
and it was a huge win for us.
To where we're not doing
that amount of work
for a smaller amount of money.
So we're starting to get there
but it's just
- It's a process.
- [Man] Yeah.
- Let them know where your strategy's at.
That's important.
It's important.
- [Man] Cool, thank you.
- [Man] So I initially
didn't have any questions
until I was here.
- Good.
- [Man] I mean generally, mind
set, like everything else,
I've been listening to you for seven years
and so you've penetrated
me very, very, very much.
And for that I thank you
for the rest of my life.
And it's great to have an
opportunity to say that.
But there's a few things
that I was curious about.
Like I've come across distributors
and like on all the social platforms
I've come across distributors
but I treat it more like a
personal brand than anything.
So I'm just documenting my own day
but it's still under the business name
- Thank you.
- [Man] Like personal
brand, business brand,
blend of the two.
I've seen you so so seamlessly,
it's hard to tell the difference.
I think that's kind of what
I'm trying to do as well.
- Yeah I think the
reason that works for me
and I think it's something
that I recommend is
I just don't think about it.
I think people think there's,
try to over think it.
You know, like live your life.
You know, it's similar
to the advice I gave you.
There's a lot of people
that wouldn't have given
the advice that I just gave you.
The business book
ideologies consolidate it.
There's a lot of people
that are giving you advice
about your personal
brand and your businesses
that went to business school
and are executives in
companies and they give advice.
The reason I love this session, this part,
is I get to give you contextual advice
after you've been watching
higher level, theoretical advice
for a while.
I listen, right?
And then I answer.
So like, you know, people are like, Gary!
This is the favorite of
every smart person I know.
Gary, what happens to Vayner
if you get hit by a bus?
And I go, it goes out of business.
And they're flabbergasted.
They're like, what's
your contingency plan?
I'm like, life insurance.
They're like, what do you mean.
I'm like, when I die, if I died
by a car accident right now,
it's really awesome that I
bought so much life insurance
based on my potential earnings
that my family will at least
achieve some percentage
of that ROI which I'm not
even that pumped about
because I'm on a new kick of
not giving my kids anything
let alone, like,
I'm on a whole different,
I used to make fun of Warren
Buffet and Bill Gates,
because I come from immigrants,
it's like you give your
family, like right?
It was like, fuck those motherfuckers.
Now I'm like, they're brilliant.
Your kids are losers on day
one if you give them too much.
Anyway, nonetheless,
I say to them, it goes out of business
and they're flabbergasted.
I'm like, bro let me,
and then I go into, and usually these are
non-entrepreneurs giving advice.
I go, let me tell you
something about Nike and Amazon
and Puma and Chase Bank.
It is far more likely
that the CEO of Coca Cola
turns every six, seven years,
than me getting hit by a bus.
And the second it does, that
company changes forever.
I don't care what happens to
VaynerMedia when I'm dead.
I'm pissed that I died.
You know what I mean?
Like people are so confused.
So anyway back to this answer.
Blend them!
Play!
What?
When a companies comes to try to buy it,
they're gonna want you
there for three years anyway
and lock you in to be the executive
that hands it off anyway.
And so whatever personal
brand equity you have,
you're gonna be able to trade on,
at best, guess what,
after you leave after three years,
you'll still have your personal brand
and start your next shit.
I moved very seamlessly
from wine to marketing
and I'll move very
seamlessly from marketing
to sports card dealer.
- [Man] There's one other weakness
that I'm really hard on,
is picking up the phone
and saying, buy my weed.
I have a hard time being super salesy.
- Hire somebody.
- [Man] Okay, thank you.
- You're welcome.
(laughing)
That is the fundamental
answer to everything
you're not good at.
Hire somebody that is good at it.
Know it well enough to know
if they're doing it well.
Got it?
- [Man] Yes sir.
- [Woman] Know it well enough to know
that they're doing it well.
- Correct.
Just enough.
Sales is easy.
I've hired you.
I have a set expectation of what I pay you
and what I kind of have
a feel for my business.
That's easy.
Somebody to do your social media marketing
when you have no idea
about social media is hard.
You don't even know what they're doing.
Got it?
Know it well
and what makes me super
interesting, I think,
is I'm dangerous enough in
everything that my company does.
But I don't need to be the best at it.
I'm just the best at the
holistic version of it.
I don't think anybody in
my company can beat me
one on one, but a lot of
people can have better skills
within the subcultures of the craft.
- [Man] Cool, thanks Gary.
- That whole, what's that brother?
- [Man] I brought a couple items later on
- Thank you.
- [Man] If wouldn't mind
whipping out and signing
- Happy to do it.
- [Man] Would mean the world.
- Happy to do it brother.
That whole, I don't even really know what
a renaissance man is,
but I think when people
throw it at me on social
they talk about like,
you do a lot of things.
And I'm like, seems practical.
You know, like, seems practical
when you own a business
for you to be dangerous
enough to know everything
so that you don't become vulnerable.
People sometimes say to me, I
don't deal with my finances.
I'm like, you're in trouble.
You have a business.
I don't like finances at all.
This is literally, I just sign everything.
Everything my lawyers, my
team puts in front of me.
But you have to know it enough.
You have to at least
understand basic like,
do I make more money than I lose?
Every time like ...
I have a great CFO,
Allen, and he loves to.
Like I'm so offense, he's
like so much more disciplined.
He razzes and sometimes
he likes to elude to like
he's the grown up
and I laugh and I'm like,
bro, I've been in business
for 20 years of my life,
have made every payroll in my life.
It's street shit, family business.
I may not, like,
I do not know the tax law the way you do
that can maximize some
of our opportunities
and I'm pumped and that's why a pay you
a fuck load of money.
But I make my payroll.
You know, you just gotta be basic.
Shit's basic.
Business is basic.
The reason I'm so cynical
to the current state
of entrepreneurship is we
have students in business now.
Business is basic.
- [Man] We're having a great
year, it's going really well.
We're about to be
growing, doubling in size,
which is going from two
restaurants to four.
So we're super excited.
- And do your partners have ambitions
for it to be a national product?
- [Man] So we have successfully
failed over the years.
We grew to five locations out of state.
We had three in Kansas
City and two in Cincinnati.
- Franchise model or your owned?
- [Man] No, we owned and operated.
- Keep going.
- [Man] Me and my
culinary partner, Jordan,
it's just two of us.
- Love it.
- [Man] So we were out there
a lot going back and forth
anyways, couldn't get it off the ground.
Shut them down focused on Denver,
since then Denver's
just been like awesome.
So super stoked.
- Cliche, you were stretched too thin.
When you focused, it worked.
- [Man] A hundred percent.
We grew and we shouldn't
have, then stretched too thin.
It was a silly idea,
I think to start with.
And then we just kind of
reshuffled and now it's actually
clicking and working.
- When things fail it's very
obvious to look backwards
and be like, right.
- [Man] Why'd we do that?
One of my tactics with
kind of that retrench
is really to pull thing in.
Where I'm even designing our website now.
I'm managing our MailChimp myself
and really kind of bringing all this in.
- I'm a big fan of pulling
in and pulling back out.
- [Man] And that was
going to be my question
is that people say well
that's not sustainable,
that's not sustainable.
And I'm like, yeah I know.
- In theory.
- [Man] The next three to five years.
- Right, in theory.
- [Man] How do you choose what to give up?
When do you starting
thinking about the future?
- The delta between the
things I like the most.
- [Man] 'Cause I want to hold it all
for as long as possible, right?
- The things I like
the most and the things
I'm best at, I keep.
And the things I don't like
and the things I'm not best at
I try to systematically
give away over time.
- [Man] Okay.
Cool just look at what--
- Self awareness and happiness
is the answer to your question.
There's just certain,
like what are we doing here?
You have a business to
do you what you like.
Like fuck it, if you can't,
you know how many people build a business
that then the business eats them
and it becomes a job?
And the thing you didn't want
to do like everybody else
or the thing you ran away
from becomes the thing
with the added pressure and
loneliness of entrepreneurship?
So the things I like and
the things I'm best at.
You know?
But there is,
I love treading everything back in.
- [Man] It's exciting
and fun and I love it.
- You also hone your skills
and then you get better at
judging the people you bring in
the next time.
All of a sudden, your email marketing head
is not going to be able to
trick you that they suck
because you know MailChimp.
I love that feeling.
I love it.
You know?
- [Man] Follow up question.
What's the most effective way
you've found to teach culture?
I find it so weird--
- Firing.
- [Man] Firing?
- [Man] Firing, okay.
- Money where your mouth is.
Culture's easy if you're
willing to fire people
that produce money that are assholes.
- [Man] Firing, I actually
don't mind firing.
- Good, firing.
- [Man] I don't mind firing.
- So to me, what's that?
- [Man] It's just as important as hiring.
Hiring and firing, you need to do that.
- Firing's way more important.
Way more.
Because hiring is guessing.
Firing is knowing.
Caleb's ...
(laughing)
- [Man] You know that feeling.
That's funny.
- The way I hire, when
I'm left to my vices,
like cool, yeah, interested, c'mon!
- [Man] Sign me up!
So you're saying your firing
sets the tone for the culture.
- I do believe that, yes.
- [Man] 'Cause everyone
sees that as an example of
cool, we're not doing that.
- There's nothing better
than firing somebody
who's cancerous in culture.
It builds confidence.
I'm very big on that, and
then just articulating it.
I mean every day people come in here,
like into my office,
Gary, like you know, people
love fuckin' theoretics.
Gary what are we doing here?
(chuckling)
I'm like, I put out content every,
I mean, every day I've
articulated that we're building
a machine that sells shit so I can buy a,
like it's the most,
it's crazy.
People that have been here six years,
they'll walk in sometimes they'll be like,
Gary, you know, feel
like we've lost our way
here at Vayner.
Like what are we doing here?
And I literally go into like Gary V mode,
not Gary Vaynerchuk the executive,
I'm like, all right, well we're
building a marketing machine
to hone my skills and meet
people and train you guys up
and then the economy's gonna collapse
and I'm gonna buy Puma
or K-Swiss or Hershey's
we're gonna run it through.
And they're like, it's like
I've been very consistent here,
that's what we're doing here.
Right Jessie?
Like it's been super consistent.
But people love to
pontificate and theorize.
It's why I hate the advice
that you guys get from not,
I'm gonna say something
that I genuinely believe.
Anytime a non-actual
operating entrepreneur
or friend of yours gives you advice,
you should look them
dead in the face and go
you have no idea what the
fuck you're talking about.
(laughing)
It's why I've gotten really quiet.
One of the things I'm most proud of
is I talk about the
same shit in my content
because I'm not willing to go to places
where I'm not willing to go anymore.
I don't know what it's
like in those other places.
Like I have theories.
I have hypotheses, but until
you walk in a man's shoes
you just don't know.
And especially entrepreneurship.
It just, you know, people
are talking theory.
It's what people that are too
socially liberal in trouble.
And I'm socially liberal as fuck.
But like everything's great in theory.
Now go execute it.
Go read communism.
It's amazing.
No really, go read Marxism.
It's super, like, I want it.
Just doesn't, it's not how humans work.
And that's how I think about business.
Cool, yeah, you shouldn't micromanage.
That's nice.
You're going to a job tomorrow
that's going to pay you.
I have to go in here and
be the last line defense
of my business
and right now, nobody's
doing email marketing
and I haven't hired anybody to do it,
so I'm gonna do it.
Like, you know what I mean?
We're in limbo, our chief
strategy officer left last week
on family reasons.
So we're interviewing, so she's not here.
When we did Sasha, assumed the COO roles
so I'm the CEO, COO, CSO I guess
for all intents and
purpose, though I'm not.
Ebbs and flows.
I'm gonna hire somebody and
you know, ebbs and flows.
- [Man] Thank you.
- By the way there's another one.
Talk to people.
Once you have a feel of
what every person wants
and once you create a
place that's safe for them
to tell you the truth,
you got a prayer.
And take it from somebody
who's really trying,
it's super hard.
They'll tell you, I send
out fuckin' emails like
once every three months with
a video of me like, come to,
literally the video I
did last Friday was it?
I was like, if you think
that if you came and told me
your boss is a dick face,
that I would fire you
or you're in trouble, you
don't know where you work.
Yet that's the biggest fear of
every person that works here.
- [Man] Humans.
- Humans.
But, the one thing I can
control is what I do.
So even though I know
that 80 percent won't act.
It doesn't stop me from
putting out the content
in company-wide emails
once every couple months
whenever I feel inspired.
I keep hounding it.
And then people that are here
for five and a half years
will go through something
and then I'll get on the phone with them
and they're like, yeah.
And I'm like, why didn't
you come and talk to me?
And they're like, yeah.
So the local thing, I got it.
- [Man] Yeah, well one of my
biggest issues is marketing.
- Okay.
- [Man] It's just not consistent.
We outsource to another company
and it just seems like
they're always kind of
like I'm always in the dark with it.
They're not very transparent.
- Well you shouldn't, you
need to change that vendor.
- [Man] Right.
- Anybody you're paying, that
isn't willing to give you
clean information, is a problem.
Period, always.
- [Man] And I've changed
them multiple times.
- Yep, what about taking it internal?
- [Man] That's what I
was going to ask you.
Do you think that's smart of me to do--
- You should taste it.
You should try it.
Yes, it's smart of you.
You notice how I don't like
to do absolute answers.
But based on multiple times,
just learning what it looks
like, what it feels like
is a good context point.
Because when that doesn't work
then you can step back and be like,
okay this doesn't work, that doesn't work.
Or when it works, you're like,
fuck, I should've done this
all along.
You just need a context point.
There's so many things
I do that I actually
don't think are gonna work,
but I do them because I
need the reference point.
That's actually how I
built all of VaynerMedia.
Most of what I did at VaynerMedia,
2019, 18, most of what
I did at VaynerMedia
from 2015, '16, and '17, I
didn't even believe in fully.
But I needed the context point
of what big agencies look like.
And I needed to do it
within my own four walls.
And now I'm unraveling it.
- [Man] Last question.
Do you think that, 'cause growing up
my father started a little
baseball card trading business.
- This is gettin' good.
(laughing)
- [Man] I have tons of--
- Those are garbage.
- [Man] They're garbage.
- Most likely they are.
It was supply and demand issues.
The fuckin' 1980,
baseball, let's start with baseball,
1982 to 2000, to like 1999,
to Mike Trout time.
All the stuff from like '80
to 2000 is in a bad place.
Baseball.
Too much supply, not enough demand.
But like '86, '87 Fleer basketball?
Gold.
'Cause basketball's culture now.
Like nobody wants a
Tony Gwynn rookie card.
Nobody wants Wade Boggs.
Nobody wants that.
People want Jordan.
Culture.
- [Man] Culture.
Basketball won, baseball's declining.
Then, that was too much supply.
It's just supply and demand.
Honestly, that's why I understand
what's about to happen.
I'm really good at supply and demand.
And I know that the
demand for sports cards
is about to really go.
Enough to make it move against the supply.
Got it?
- [Man] Got it.
- I think basketball's
going to be incredible.
I think China's gonna get involved.
And when that happens, just
think about Asia's money
for Jordan rookies, LeBron
rookies, Kobe rookies,
Steph rookies.
It's about to happen.
It's a global sport.
And I think the sneaker thing with kids.
It's cumbersome.
These sneaker kids.
First of all you can't
get as many off whites
and Ezs and limited
edition Nikes as you want.
Even when you were right.
You're like, that's gonna be good.
The Fear of God collab is gonna work
so you can't get enough inventory.
Whereas like, if you
make a hot take right now
on Jayson Tatum and you think
he's really gonna be the guy
you can go buy 50,000 rookie cards.
Yeah, I think cards are about to explode.
- [Man] Nice.
- I'm really excited.
I can't believe it's happening, actually.
My life is getting so weird.
I started a wine brand.
I'm getting into cards.
I'm going backwards!
Feel like an old man.
It's what happens.
But yeah, no, I think it's gonna happen.
Marketing, real quick, because
I want to bring you value.
You guys do what?
Cold calling, direct mail, Google AdWords?
- [Man] Mostly Google AdWords.
- I think you should
really focus on Facebook.
- [Man] Facebook?
- The older demo, if
you're referring to that.
Are you going after older?
Or just going to any house, right?
- [Man] Uh, any house.
- How are you getting business now?
How are you getting business now?
- [Man] It's like
- Word of mouth?
- [Man] Home Advisor.
- You're in a referral business.
- [Man] Yeah.
- This is what I hate about
services for real life,
they all let all these companies that got
in between Google and them,
Home Advisor, Zillow, Open
Table in the restaurant world.
It's all the same shit.
That's what happened.
Like just to give you a quick punchline
of what happened in the world.
Google, I was right about Google AdWords.
I did a nice job and built
my dad's liquor store.
There were much smarter people than me
that built platforms that sat in between
Google and the business underneath them.
And that's who built huge, huge companies.
You gotta get out of that.
- [Man] Get out of that.
- You can't be reliant on
somebody who's a toll booth.
What if they said the price is double?
You're gonna pay.
You have no leverage.
- [Man] Right, so I need to
get on all these platforms.
I'm not on any.
- Whoever's closest to the customer wins.
When Amazon raises Prime
by 40 bucks next year,
you're gonna say thank you so much.
When Netflix raises Netflix by six bucks,
whoever's closest in
bringing the most value
to the customer wins.
You can't be in a referral-based business.
You're a sucker.
- [Man] What about local service ads?
Local service ads with Google.
- Yeah, I'm fine with that.
But you're basically in
intent-based transactional
sales mode.
And I want you to be the authority.
You're marketing to a local area.
Put out a video every day
of how people should be
maintaining their homes.
I think every service provider
should put out content
to people on Facebook of
how not to have to use them.
I believe in that the most.
I believe it the most.
It's my number one thesis.
I believe in it.
- [Man] And so,
- Do you know how many
mechanics make money
on something you could've
changed a spark plug for?
I'll give you a person that
would fall for it every time.
I have no concept of how a car works.
I'm completely baffled
by the modern automobile.
Just don't know.
Give a fuck.
(laughing)
My buddies are like, you're not a man.
I'm like fuck you!
(laughing)
Like how much money do you have?
What's the definition of a man?
You know, like cool, I don't
know how to my change my car.
I have enough money to have
multiple people change it.
I'll buy a new fuckin' car.
Doesn't work?
I'll buy a new one.
Like you know, whatever.
Everybody has their own,
but I think, you want to build trust?
Hey, I talked to a roofer friend.
You need to put out content every day
of the stuff people should be
doing to maintain their roof
so they don't have to
pay you 30,000 or 8,000.
And they've been doing
it and it's working.
- [Man] What platform would be best?
- Facebook.
- [Man] Facebook.
Facebook.
Make content, run ads against
people in the neighborhoods
that you're trying to reach.
It'll show up in their feed.
- [Man] It's kind of foreign to me
'cause you're telling me
but I've never done it.
I've only done Facebook
ads which translated
into Instagram promotions.
Is that what you're talking
about or you're talking about
actual Facebook.
- Facebook ads on Facebook
where you know exactly
what you're saying against
who you're saying it to.
Give me your best town.
- [Man] My best town?
- Yeah, that you do business in.
The name of the town.
- [Man] Granada Hills.
- Great, you make a video.
Hey Granada Hills, it's me.
I'm servicing a lot of you.
I want to service less of you.
Let me explain.
So many of you are paying
me 5,000, 10,000 dollars
to do X.
But if you actually spend
$130 a month doing this,
less of you would need me.
That is the single best
thing you could ever do
for your business.
Guys I learned this from Wine Library TV.
This is horrible.
Do not buy this.
I'm selling it!
People are watching it like
what the fuck is this guy up to?
I wasn't even sure,
I just subconsciously knew
that if I was good for the customer
that'd be good for me.
It wasn't good for this.
We were gonna have
trouble selling this now.
But in the macro, I was
building a relationship.
I'm giving away all my
marketing advice for free
so you don't have to,
like right?
Look at how meta this is!
It's all free, but you're here, paying.
Trust was built.
Then I get even more scared.
I'm like, fuck, they're
comin', they're paying.
We have to make this awesome.
The stuff that you,
the reason that you reacted
even after seven years
of like awesome is like
what we've done so far.
It's valuable.
Because you're at a big
enough business scale.
What was smart about 4Ds was
pricing it expensive enough
so that people that were coming through
weren't hoping and dreaming
and it's not a lottery ticket.
Means you're far enough along to get
a singular piece of
advice that can make the
arbitrage of $12,000 worth is.
Got it?
That's how it clicked.
Make sense?
Then you make it, apologize,
then you make it a phone call ad.
If you go older, I like the phone ads.
Where you put content but
there's a phone number
and they just click it right from there.
- [Man] That's on Facebook you're saying.
So right on the Facebook ad is a little
call to action button
or something like that.
- That's right.
- [Man] We'll set out 15 minutes next week
to run through some of this.
- [Man] Okay, cool.
- [Man] So we actually
fired our best phone rep.
We actually were about to fire them
and they let go of themselves.
Best feeling.
- It was a huge missed
opportunity for you.
Huge.
- [Man] Huge?
- You didn't make an impact in culture
because they left on their
terms, not you firing them.
Huge miss.
I mean it.
Give that thought to everybody else.
I know that you don't
run the whole company.
- [Man] What if she beat us to it though?
- She didn't.
She won the game.
You guys lost.
I'm devastated when
that happens at Vayner.
At Vayner, there's people that
are fired at Vayner right now
in my head, that it might take
me three and a half months
to make it happen for
a magnitude of reasons.
Occasionally that person
will quit and I'm devastated.
Because I wasn't able through my actions
to show the rest of the
company that we know that
that person wasn't right.
- [Man] Do you tell them that
hey, I fired this person?
- People know everything.
- [Man] Gotcha, okay.
- She got ahead of you guys.
She won.
- [Man] But even if we
wanted to let her go.
She was like a cancer.
- Your employees don't know that.
They don't believe you.
- [Man] And then they're going insane
sticking it to the
employees before they leave.
So it's like
- A hundred percent, she
controlled the narrative.
Missed opportunity but
still a good net positive.
But it's something to think about.
And I know that you don't
have all the control.
I remember kind of the narrative
from the sneaker thing.
But like, back to what
I'm trying to do here,
it's advice for everybody else.
For people that don't like to fire,
it's the double damage.
'Cause they have the
narrative, they control it.
I'm out of this, fuckin'.
They were the cancer.
They know they're not on point with you,
so they got ahead of it and
then they tell everybody
I'm living this shit place,
this place always sucked.
I leave and they have all the leverage.
Got it?
I know I'm right.
- [Man] That's the
alternative of not firing.
- Correct.
And then you have collateral damage.
- [Man] I just fired a
real problematic employee,
cultivator and ESD.
I mean he came over for
Thanksgiving dinner to my house.
He became a friend.
And then it was so hard
to fire him because
he became a personal friend.
He worked for me in my company.
So I had to bring him in
and he was blindsided.
He came in I was like,
it's not working out,
we're heading in a different direction.
He just shook his head and walked out.
But what he continued to
do is he reached out to
every retailer that I work with
and told them lies about me.
If I hadn't fired him
and he'd done that while
he was still an employee,
it would've been the double damage.
- You gotta always control the narrative.
I'm telling you, notice how I reacted?
It's one of my most difficult
things running this co.
'Cause sometimes there's
reasons not to fire somebody
whether I gotta transition a client.
One of the biggest reasons
I don't fire clients is
I have to build equity with
the three or four people
around them because they've
already been doing cancer.
And I gotta siphon the equity
to me before I fire them.
Yeah.
Sally's shit, her crew is
being manipulated by Sally.
I like that crew and there's
a lot of great people.
I've gotta spend two months
between me and other managers
to build equity with
them so they understand
Sally's garbage.
And then you get rid of Sally.
Because if you get rid
of Sally before then,
they leave too.
It's the most funny thing ever.
It's like parents.
Remember all the shit you
thought your parents didn't know?
But then you got older and they're like,
I fuckin' knew you were
jumpin' out the window
and hooking up with Rick!
You're like, fuck, Mom!
How'd you know?
'Cause you know!
I love when my employees
think I don't know.
I fuckin' know everything.
(laughing)
Right Nick?
That was like an evolution, right?
It's interesting right?
- [Nick] That would be a long time ago.
- You're super on it.
Anyway.
That's not you're question, go ahead.
- [Man] So I'm looking
for some perspective
and strategy in auto.
So Agent2021 I had a good time.
Good things and bad
things I liked about it.
But it got me thinking of more ideas
and I wanted to know,
so I was like, man, I can build
a machine here really well
as a company.
But then look, we started
interviewing big bloggers,
content creators,
and I wanted to know when it
comes to the best strategy,
I don't know the best way to figure out
where are these going.
I know there's a few
companies like Carvana,
they're like getting rid
of the dealership shit
'cause there's a new way to buying a car.
So I was like, we'll
just be the car buyer.
We'll just strictly buy and we wholesale
all of our cars, we'll sell
them to franchise dealerships.
But is that just for like,
should I be thinking
more of how can I help
everyone in all dealerships?
Or hey, is this where we
should be going down the--
- Tier three dealer auto
dealerships are going to be around
for minimally another decade
'cause you haven't seen
enough transition happen yet.
Let's start with that.
- [Man] Transition in like
- Meaning you're not seeing
car dealerships close
all the time.
You're not seeing Ford
announce that they're
not going to do tier three anymore.
There hasn't been
anything that's happened,
and even when Ford
says, we're gonna not do
dealerships anymore, it's
gonna take them five years
'cause there's deals in place.
So I think a lot of time
people see the future
but don't realize how long it takes.
I made that mistake.
In 1998, I decided,
we launched in '96, I start
running the company in '98,
the store.
And I decide by the year
2000, it was 18 months,
this is what's so funny about being a kid,
you think 18 months is a million years.
I'm like, by the year 2000,
I'll never forget this,
I couldn't have been more wrong.
By the year 2000, everybody
will come into my wine store
and scan every bar code because I made up
that phones would have
scanners on them by then.
And they'll know the price of every wine
and I'm gonna have to lower the price
and be the lowest price on everything
'cause I still to this day
don't know when you sell,
when you sell a service,
you can talk about it
from a service standpoint.
I still don't know how
to explain to somebody,
if I sell a bottle of wine,
why somebody else is selling it cheaper,
why they should buy it from me.
I do not understand.
And I never did, and
that's why Wine Library
had the best prices on
every wine in America
when I ran the store.
Because I don't understand
what the answer to that question is.
And so, I lowered the prices
of every single product.
Crushed are margin, but it never happened.
We still don't have it.
And that's how I've gotten good.
If you notice, I know a
lot of you guys follow,
I'm so much more right than everybody else
about VR 24 months ago when
everybody was talking about it.
Right?
Everybody was all,
getting fired up.
And I was like, it's not even close.
And here we are 24 months later.
And still nothing has happened.
Not even the beginnings of something.
Same thing that's happening
with machine learning
and AI right now.
Everyone's talking about it every day.
And I'm like, that's cool.
And there's a lot more going on there.
But the things that people
say it's going to do
are 13 years from now.
So yes, do I think cars are
going direct to consumer?
Yes I do.
Do I think it's going to
take a decade to three?
I do.
The end.
And I think youngster who are progressive
could get caught on the
timing of innovation.
Got it?
I think that you are
because you haven't lived
through a couple cycles,
are gonna see things that are right
'cause you're digitally
native, you're younger,
you're coming from a
different perspective.
It's gonna take longer than you think
for it to materialize.
I believed that online dating
was going to be mainstream
in 1998.
It really probably, I mean
match.com at some level,
but like, Tinder in 2012,
I'm trying to think now,
it took a long time, but
I knew it would happen,
but nobody believed me when it happened.
It's like sports cards right now.
It's already happened, I
know it's gonna happen.
Most people are looking at me like
oh you just, 'cause you
liked it when you were,
they don't see it yet.
- [Man] Last question.
So with that I have all these ideas
but I think that as a company
we need more money to do it.
I think we need more capital so
I guess, what do you do at that point?
Where do you go?
- Do you have control?
- [Man] So they are open.
We've talked about, there's four of us,
and we talked about should
we fix everything first
and then ask for money?
Or just ask for money
and then go from there?
- Well first, can you make
money instead of asking for it?
Or no?
- [Man] Yeah, so we're profitable.
- Can you make more?
- [Man] We can but
sometimes it gets very tight
when it comes to
- I got it.
- [Man] So if the car
doesn't sell at auction,
it'll get really tight.
And sometimes if you
wanna go more it'll get
- Look, I think raising
capital on your terms
and your advantage is a good idea.
I don't think that's how
it ends up most times.
Whoever's asking for the
money has less leverage.
So I'm a big fan of creating something
that has people asking to give you money.
Whoever asks first, blinked.
That's how I think about that.
- [Man] Thank you.
- So many questions.
- Let's go.
- All right, so
in building my personal
brand I already speak.
But I want to do more speaking.
However, I'm a mom of
three and they're it.
- Of course, yeah of course.
Have you gotten remarkable
at eliminating other things
besides those two things?
- [Woman] Yep, I'm good there.
- Good, okay.
- [Woman] How do I train
from the beginning because I feel like
this is a beginning for me,
anyone who reaches out to me
about a speaking engagement
that I can bring just
as much value from my
cute pink velvet couch in my
office, ring light, whatever.
No?
- That's what you want,
it's not what they want.
- [Woman] I mean, there's nothing I can do
to make that possible?
- Nope, I do not believe so.
I close people paying me
185,000 to give a speech.
8000 times easier than I close people
paying me 35,000 to simulcast it.
And that's consistent for everybody.
It's experience.
- [Woman] So I'll just have
to put off traveling so much
because I just can't do it, I won't do it.
- There's another thing.
Charge more.
Right?
If you're willing to not
travel, you now have leverage.
So it's like, you shouldn't
say no, you should ask
for a remarkable amount more
than you're accustomed to now.
That's what I did.
When I started building VaynerMedia,
I was like, okay now I'm
gonna build VaynerMedia.
Jess were you there,
were you there before I
was kind of day to day CEO?
Or you came right as I was kind of there?
Yeah, so what's really interesting,
you might've saw, like VaynerMedia
because we formed the LLC on April 15th,
even though AJ wasn't out
of school yet, turned 10.
But for me it's always eight,
because I really didn't
operate this business the first two years
because I was busy with Wine Library.
I was really, still really running that.
And then I crush it and the
whole Gary V thing was starting.
And so when I decided in September 2011
to run VaynerMedia for real,
to actually be the CEO,
I didn't want to speak
as much 'cause I wanted
to build the business.
So I moved my fee from 5,000 to 15,000.
And what ended up happening
was, it was awesome
because okay, a bunch of
people said go fuck yourself,
you think you're a big shot, right?
And that was fine.
But some people said yes.
And I was like, really, okay, amazing.
So I don't know what you're charging now,
but if you're willing not to travel
'cause you gotta be
home more and whatever.
You're gonna find a new remarkable thing
which is you might be able to get more.
I'll never forget that year where like,
the year prior, I spoke
like 11 or 15 or 22 times.
And the next year I spoke like seven
but made the same money.
It was a really powerful moment.
Now, I had momentum, you
know, it's a marketplace.
But yes, as fact, anytime somebody says
I'm looking to become a speaker,
I'm always like, speak as much as you can
for as free as much as you can.
I mean look, you've got your life.
And I think it's really hard,
it's really hard for everybody,
but I have double empathy for a mom
because I think there's just inherent,
you birthed it, this human, kind of thing.
And there's social.
And social pressures and how you grew up
and ideologies of your
grandmother's grandmother
that trickle down.
It's hard to balance to begin with.
- But I can do it.
- But it's better than
having terminal cancer.
(laughing)
It definitely feels like that.
It's fun to pontificate.
You're really thrilled right now
that you do not have terminal cancer.
And that's where I always go.
Like hey it sucks that maybe
you can't go 150 percent
on the business because you
have parenting obligations
and wants and needs and ambitions.
You could've been born in Cambodia
and not had the same opportunities you had
at being a white woman in America.
Like I'm always playing the,
this pisses me off, but I
can spend the rest of my life
talking about all the
things that are worse.
I do believe in that perspective.
'Cause you'll get crippled otherwise.
- I appreciate you recognizing that.
- I believe that.
Like I hate when dudes
are like, it's the same.
It's the least same thing of all time.
- Yeah, so I'm ready to
start my pillar content.
And the trickle down which
I'm really excited about.
- Podcast, vlog, what're you thinking?
- I'm not sure.
So camera is where I--
- Shine?
- I've been my whole life.
So it's what I do.
And I feel like I can deliver my message
just differently than a lot of people.
So I want to start with video.
- I'm a big fan of videoing a podcast.
- Me too, okay good.
This is what I was thinking
the other day, that's great.
- I'm a big fan of it.
You get both, film, the podcast.
We've all seen it right,
like IMUS sports radio,
Mike & Mike, you've seen it on cable TV.
It's a radio show being filmed
which means it's at TV show.
It's exactly the same for us.
- I think my strength though,
comes from the training aspect
just kind of what you do.
So it's soundbites.
- You should do a Q&A show.
Watch what I do, not what I say.
When I came back, seven years,
what are we 19,
so you know this.
My career has a really funny moment in it
which is when I went
double down on Vayner.
Like September 2011 to like '13, '14
I was pretty quiet, for
me, on the internet.
There's very little, if you look at it,
there's only the keynotes,
there's like a couple things.
I was very quiet.
And then when I came back,
I was more self-aware
and what did I start?
The Ask Gary V show.
Sometimes when I talk to
Caleb or anybody on my team,
I'm the breakout personality
in the business space
in the last couple years
while actively being a CEO and COO
of a massive company.
And when I talk to them,
like could you imagine
if I was just Gary V?
Like every morning I would
do a fuckin' morning show
from like 8 a.m. to 11 a.m. just Q&A
and you think I'm penetrating
all the channels now?
It'd be over.
I'd do it every day.
It's my favorite thing to do.
Tea With Gary V.
Nice glass of tea, just put him on.
Call me, boom, boom,
boom, boom, boom, boom,
clip, clip, clip,
distribute, distribute.
Every day.
Looked how pumped we get,
one of the reasons I did
4Ds was for the fuckin'
what did I just say?
The firing,
like it's fuckin' good.
I can't wait for that piece of content.
The guessing, knowing,
that fuckin' thing's
gonna kill on LinkedIn.
That's two million in the bank.
(laughing)
But I need to be asked.
It's hard to self start.
It's not, I apologize.
I'm really great at self starting,
that's why I was good.
It just I'm only going
to say the same things
that I believe in.
The only time I do new
shit is when I'm asked.
That's why I started
and if you know that about yourself,
make it a Q&A show, right?
- Which is so much fun.
- So fun especially when you stay in your,
the biggest thing I'll tell
you, just stay in your lane.
I think a lot of people
when they start Q&A
have a sense of like I'm an
expert, I should have an answer
for this.
It happened yesterday,
I don't know, right?
What was that?
I was pumped.
I don't know, nonetheless I
was super pumped to tell them,
like I don't know.
I love that.
- [Man] I've been doing
a Q&A with my photography
just before this and no questions.
I didn't have enough engagement yet.
So is there a certain
time you want to start
and launch a Q&A?
- I'll give you a good one though.
For people out there who
want to start a Q&A show
that nobody knows in the world.
Let's say you want to.
Go to Twitter.
Search terms.
Find questions that people
are actually asking the ethos
and answer them.
By the way, by the way, that
is the actual origin story
of Gary V.
Nobody in the world knew who I was
when I started Wine Library TV.
I went on Twitter, searched wine terms,
and answered questions.
Because I knew what I was
talking about about wine.
Nobody knew that I knew.
- [Man] Got it, thank you.
- So literally, you should go watch an old
Ask Gary V.
I make the image from
the question on Twitter
but you could do that with somebody
not asking you the question.
John in Albuquerque asked,
not me, but the world, so I'll answer it.
What should I do when my, you know.
What else?
How much time do I have?
- [Man] Officially ten.
- Ten more minutes?
- [Man] We could do
five and then a picture.
- Okay, anything else?
- This is nothing, just my brand.
- Good.
- Ask it anyway?
- Of course.
- So I just read
Titan, no, you were asked in a book,
Mentors, Tribe of Mentors.
- [Man] Ferriss.
- Ferris or Gonan?
- [Man] Ferris.
- I think it was Titans, right?
- [Man] There's two.
- Oh there's two?
- Two different ones.
- Timmy's a fuckin' beast.
He just writes.
- Let me tell you what you said.
You said you had someone
that travels with you
that does personal training
and then body work.
- Yes, oh soft tissue work.
I'm doing it right now.
I don't know if you
noticed what I'm doing,
I'm literally
- So the whole fascia thing.
- I'm literally doing it right now.
- So I want to know, 'cause
I just entered this world.
- I'm literally doing it right now.
- Tell me what it does.
Because this has been
brought to my attention
and I feel like I need it.
- So I don't really know.
But here's what I know.
If you continuously rub
with a ball, with your fist,
with a fork on this,
there is a soft tissue, there's
a fascia that is built up,
I have it so bad right here.
So I hurt back when I was
a kid in the liquor store.
So what ended up happening
was subconsciously
and I can see it in old videos,
I would do this.
And what happened was that
became my actual posture.
And in that slight bend,
there's just a lot of gunk built up here.
And as I've learned to stretch out,
it's still here.
I mean, this fuckin' hurt.
And when I tell you,
here's the craziest part about this game.
Right now, if like, I'm gonna show you.
(chuckling)
Sorry, I know this is
(laughing)
- You're welcome.
- Look at this.
Like I have to go,
like I'm literally bruising.
- [Man] Oh wow.
- What you don't know
is how crazy this is.
Here's why.
I've now been on this
for like three years.
And I've only discovered
that I have more tissue stuff
to do around my IT band
here, three weeks ago.
And I'm like poking and
prodding constantly.
And you don't even
your brain doesn't want you to touch it.
This is real.
Your brain is keeping you away from it.
It's this crazy game.
I wish Jordan was here.
You're almost playing against yourself.
You don't even realize it's happening.
But there is literally
places in your body right now
where you have fascia
and soft tissue issues
that you have no idea that it's happening
and the second you hit it,
it like blows your mind.
- [Man] It like your psoas.
- Oh my psoas.
Dude, first of all,
everything was fucked up on me
when I started.
All of it.
- [Man] You can really
stretch out your psoas.
- The psoas is nuts.
The first, you know where it started?
My adductor.
The first thing that ever happened.
Jordan's very good at soft tissue work.
And he did it for baseball players
'cause they get a lot of gunk and stuff.
And I was doing something
and he's like hey
and I almost jumped out of the gym.
You have to understand,
it's right here.
It's right here, right?
It's like in place,
it's not like some weird,
it's right here.
I have no idea what he's talking about.
He goes, huh.
I go, phew!
It was so fucked up, so tight.
Anyway, like there's a stick that he has
that's the best, the blue
ball, like all this shit.
Like it's changed my life.
Here's why.
Actually I'm gonna show you guys.
I think I have a picture of it.
This is so crazy to me.
God I really hope I have this.
I gotta show you something that is almost
uncomfortably ridiculous.
I'm gonna show you a picture,
yep here we go.
I'm so hopeful that I have it.
Okay here we go.
- [Man] Is this everything?
- Yeah, I showed it to you.
- [Man] Put it on the screen.
- What?
- [Man] Troy posted it a while ago.
- Really, you have it?
I think I might have it.
- You really have everything.
- Guys when I tell you
that I'm so passionate
about you guys doing this.
It's (exhales)
it changed my life.
Let me tell you how.
I sleep better.
When I travel I feel better.
I feel better just second to second.
Way more than losing weight.
Way more than having muscles.
It's changed the way I actually walk
and maneuver around life.
I'm so in tune with
myself and all this stuff,
but I gotta tell you,
I don't know how to explain it.
It is, shit I don't have it.
You have it, you finding it?
- [Man] I'll find it.
- Text Jordan real quick,
he'll text it to you.
I just found the one.
It's so crazy guys.
This hurts so,
like I'm barely touching in
between two ribs right now.
Anyway oh god.
So QL, I don't know how educated
people are on this shit.
I don't even know if I'm
using the right word,
but there's a QL muscle right here,
and I'm like it's still bothering me.
Anyway, what he's looking for,
you're gonna see a picture of me
when Jordan really figured
out the biggest issue
which was my QL,
I had to do this.
And he said, okay, turn
your legs like this,
put your hand here.
And then I want you to do this,
and I want you to go this way.
And what you'll see in the picture is
I go like this far and I wasn't
even able to keep this hand
free, I used it to brace
and my face looks like this.
And now, what I'm able to do.
You know, like.
Like really able to go.
And I can have my
but this whole thing was so tight
that I wasn't able to even move.
Like I'm not joking, I really can't wait
for you guys to see it.
It's one year exactly apart.
I literally was like this.
(laughing)
And what's crazy is
you don't even know it.
Like I don't know how to explain it.
You don't even know that's
because it becomes your norm.
Oh man, you found it?
Are you gonna throw it up here?
I'm so pumped right now.
- Does this tissue work
have a specific name?
- Yes, structural integrative,
hold on, hold on.
- Dude on, I'm so fucked
up still on my QL.
Fuck it hurts.
- I'll get it.
- This new spot is just not.
Dude I'm so pumped to see this.
You got it?
- [Man] Could we ask
you a question while--
- Yes a hundred percent.
- [Man] Do you ever feel
like you get like too famous?
- Look at this.
Guys, look at this!
This is me with all my might,
trying to go to the left.
I'm going nowhere, hand support, dead.
One year later.
(laughing)
- [Man] Is that with the human garage?
- What's that?
Did you go with him at the human garage?
- I don't know, what's that?
- [Man] It's just like
some people out of Venice
they work on your fascia.
- No this is just, but
one more time, scroll.
Think about that.
- [Man] Wow.
- And what you don't
what that actually means
is things like, I got one,
when I now go for something,
I used to do this.
Oh actually, here's a good one.
Because how fucked up I was left to right,
when Jordan was like pick up a weight
and right hand, weight over here,
I would just do this.
But when he was like pick up that weight,
I would do this.
I had no range.
I used to, I mandate to be on
the left side of the airplane
because when I would be on the right side
and try to sleep, this wouldn't stretch.
Like crazy shit that you
would never think about.
It changed my life.
Another thing that's
about to change my life is
I'm gonna send you this.
Dio, I want you to put this up.
This is gonna segue to my next thing.
Do I ever think I'm getting too famous?
- [Man] Yeah, like do you
get too much to handle?
People stopping you?
- I can't stop it.
I like it too much.
It's the good outweighs the bad.
And not about the selfishness of
I like being famous.
It's that I feel too good when
I'm changing somebody's life.
I can't replicate the high
of somebody emailing me
and saying I was abused.
Guys, you don't know what I get.
Yeah!
- [Man] What are those.
- I have bought 43.
So listen to my hot take on this.
(laughing)
I believe that this is the number one
under priced card in the world.
Now you guys all know,
I hate Michael Jordan more than breathing.
I've never worn a pair
of Jordans, I hate 'em.
But, this is the number
one under priced product
in the world right now.
This is a Michael Jordan
rookie sticker card,
not the regular card.
The regular card's 5,000 when
it's graded a nine like this.
This is how they grade them.
They put them in cases
and then they give them a
you can see the nine
there, ten is the best.
This card is selling for like a thousand.
I started buying them a couple months ago
when they were 700, but
I'm driving up the price
'cause it's just drying up.
But I think this card
should be worth just as much
as the regular $6000 one
because there's just as many made of this
as the regular one,
and these are even
harder to get good grades
'cause the stickers
were even more awkward.
So I'm gonna buy them all, that I can,
there's still,
I mean I have 67 or 47,
I'm gonna try to buy 500,
there's probably hundreds of thousands.
And them I'm gonna tell my whole community
to go and buy them.
And then I'm gonna educate people on why
in supply and demand, normal non-emotion,
this should equally be worth $6000.
And I think it'll then go to $6000.
- Can I buy one?
- Yep, you can go on eBay and you should
honestly back to my whole game of like
people have no money and
I'm trying to get them
a thousand dollars by
flipping one dollar to this.
This whole sports card thing,
the reason I'm most passionate,
the number one question I have
that I do not know how to answer,
which pisse me off is,
hey Gary, I have $18,000
how should I invest it?
It's a tricky number.
Like what real estate do you buy?
Facebook, Netflix stock?
This.
I really think that cards
are gonna go up so much
and be so liquid that a lot of people
if they're really smart,
and I'm gonna tell them what to buy
after I buy a little for myself.
I'll be able to turn 18s into hundreds.
I think somebody can easily,
easily, it's scary to
me how realistic turning
$18,000 into $100,000
in sports cards will be
over the next 18 months.
I really believe that.
- [Man] I have one of those
Michael Jordan 24 karat gold
- Garbage.
- Aw.
- No, no, listen, I
have unlimited garbage.
I have so much garbage.
Everything you have.
Everything's garbage in that.
But like,
- [Man] I heard you mention
about the Hakeem Olajuwon
is that longer term?
- That's a 30 year play.
I'm buying up all Hakeems
'cause I think Africa culture
is gonna be like a major,
I think China and Africa
Africa's the next continent to blow up.
And I think African culture
and basketball's global
and Joel Embiid and Africa
and Hakeem's a great one.
Yeah, very simply, I believe in 34 years
that I will sell a ton of my
Hakeem Olajuwon rookie cards
that I'm buying for 200 bucks now
to African business men
and women for $4000.
- [Man] Why do you think
it's becoming so big?
Because the kids are getting back into it?
The new generation?
- Three things.
One, I think that 43 year
olds are now at an age
where they have six and seven
year olds that are into it
and we're playing the nostalgia play
the same reason G.I. Joe
and Strawberry Shortcake
reboot every 30 years.
This is what we always do.
We want our kids to do what we did.
It's like a thing.
Two, sneaker flipping.
All these 16, 17, 18 year old
hucksters, hustlers like me
are in sneaker flipping,
but they can't get enough supply.
When they're right, they have
to wait online, buy one pair
and make 600 bucks.
When you're right about Jordan
or Giannis or Steph Curry,
you can buy 40,000 of them.
So it's the graduation step to the kids
that are doing sneakers for the flip.
Three, gambling.
There's going to be Zion cards.
One of the things that's
happening in sports cards now
is you can get one of one,
like it's the only card like
that in the world.
Signature cards, pieces of the jersey,
limited edition stuff.
Supply and demand.
There's only 25 of these
Zions in the world.
There's only 25.
There's a billion Ken
Griffey Jr. Rookie cards.
Got it?
So, soon, once people actually
understand what's happening
with sports cards,
there's gonna be a knowledge base,
even like people in my office, just life,
that you can go into a
card store or Walmart,
buy an eight dollar
pack of Prism basketball
and you could pull a $40,000 Zion rookie.
And unlike a lottery
ticket, you could pull out
the regular Zion that's worth $25.
So gambling.
And because of daily fantasy and gambling,
people watch more sports when they care.
So one of the things
people will do is like
if you think like I do, like
De'Aaron Fox is gonna be a
very good basketball player,
I'm buying up a ton of De'Aaron
Fox rookie cards right now.
'Cause I think he's very good.
And next year, I'm actually gonna care
what the Sacramento Kings
are doing every night.
'Cause I have financial vested interested
and De'Aaron Fox is going from $14 bucks
that I'm buying him now to 40 bucks.
Five minutes ago I could
care less if Luca Doncic
got hurt or Dallas did well.
I'm buying 700 Luca rookie
cards for next year,
and so now I care.
People like to do things to
make them care about things.
That's why they bet.
It's not just trying to make money.
It's that you all of a sudden you care
to watch that playoff game tonight.
It enhances the experience.
(rock music)